bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7-8 société
les universités peine à boucler leur
budget certaines affichent d'ailleurs
des déficits si l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin réduit son
déficit en passant de 5,2 millions
d'euros à 900000 euros
les dotations d'état deviennent moins
importante elle oblige les
établissements à trouver des solutions
alternatives
et si la solution une des solutions en
tout cas passé aussi par l'appel aux
dons tout simplement un tout simplement
la loi lru sur l'autonomie des
universités l'autorisent en tout cas et
l'université de versailles saint quentin
par le biais de fondations vient
d'ailleurs de lancer aujourd'hui même
une collecte de fonds pour financer les
ouvrages de la bibliothèque
universitaire comment fonctionne cette
fondation quel rôle peuvent qui jouait
les donateurs fait rentrer des fonds
privés au sein d'un établissement public
que faut-il en penser
pour répondre à ces questions et aussi
peut-être pour débattre mais deux
invités les cariocas net bonsoir vous
êtes professeur des universités et
président de la fondation ups qu
directeur de directeur par don de la
fondation ups qu en tamoul bonsoir vous
êtes étudiant en master 2
sociodémographiques université de
versailles saint quentin
vous avez fait toutes vos études à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
mais vous êtes l'un des donateurs
justement de cette fondation
vous avez d'ailleurs ouvert un blog sur
la question alors je les dis la
fondation vient de lancer un appel aux
dons pour financer des ouvrages qu'ils
viendront compléter ceux de la
bibliothèque universitaire vous avez
dansé à l'appel aux dons pour financer
jusqu'à 300 mille euros ça paraît une
somme importante
trois cent mille euros si vous reporter
ça au global de la bibliothèque
universitaire qui est d'à peu près six
cent mille euros en frais de
fonctionnement et de 3 millions d'euros
en masse salariale ce qui c'est l'effort
que l'uni à cet effet pour sa
bibliothèque c'est relativement modérée
trois cent mille euros ça correspond en
fait on a demandé aux
des responsables de biotech dire
idéalement qu'est ce que ce qu'est ce
qu'il faudrait acheter cette année pour
mettre à jour et développer le fond mais
qu'on comprenne pourquoi il ya besoin de
lancer un appel aux dons pour financer
des livres ça veut dire que nick sont
pas suffisamment financé n'y a pas assez
d'argent principe c'est l'état qui doit
financer des ouvrages
alors le budget l'université c'est un
budget global avec des choses qui sont
qui sont ventilés c'est surtout que pour
la levée de la fondation en chercher en
fait un sujet qu'ils soient d'abord
centré ses démarrages de la fondation
donc c'est particulièrement important
pour nous et on cherchait un sujet
qu'ils soient centrées sur les étudiants
qu'ils soient du fondamental du savoir
ouvert sur le territoire et qui met sur
la table la question l'investissement de
long terme et qui s'adresse à toutes les
facultés toutes les disciplines et le
meilleur sujet comment être sûrs pour ça
c'est la bibliothèque c'est pour les
étudiants toutes les disciplines sont
concernées
c'est d'investissement de long terme et
c'est du savoir du fondamental alors
c'est un appel aux dons qu'a été lancé
depuis le mois d'octobre
oui mais qui sera lancé jusqu'en juin
de 15 il ya eu pour l'instant à peu près
à 26 mille euros collectés là depuis on
va dire depuis depuis aujourd'hui
est-ce que c'est satisfaisant les
premières disons qu'il y a des des dons
des promesses de dons qui sont en cours
de traitement et qui devrait être
officialisée je pense assez rapidement
et qui montreront que déjà il y à des
résultats plus substantielles que cela
là mais c'est une course de fond c'est
une course de fond c'est difficile le
contexte est quand même difficile pour
tout le monde il faut le reconnaître on
est conscient et donc que cela demandera
beaucoup de travail pour arriver à
l'objectif
or parmi les donateurs il ya vous
entendre vous êtes un grand grand
donateur ma donateurs quand même
alex par rapport à mon salaire mensuel
je suis un grand donateur expliqué donc
j'ai mené avant toute chose il faut dire
quand même que j'ai effectivement donné
pour cette fondation parce que je suis
attachée à mon université
je pense que chacun peut être attaché à
son université et participer à la vie de
son université de façon économique plan
politique mais avant toute chose il
faudrait dire quand même que
l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines comme toutes les universités
publiques de france ne se sont pas fait
ce sont pas construites sur des dons
c'est l'état providence qui a mis en
place ces universités qui les financent
et je pense que la fondation n'est pas
un outil de remplacement de du
financement de l'université est ce que
c'est très important ce deuxième titre
emplacements non parce qu'on vous dit
l'abbé us et des biotech par
l'universitaire ces six cent mille euros
et là il ya trois cent mille euros
d'appel aux dons est ce que une
fondation n'a pas vocation à se
substituer au financement de l'état la
fondation à la porte des moyens
supplémentaires pour aller plus loin par
rapport à ce qu'on souhaite faire
et aujourd'hui dans la stratégie de
développement et de concurrence qu'il ya
entre les universités les budgets de
l'état ne suffisent pas pour affirmer la
singularité des
les universités et dans ce cas rien
antonov a d'abord on remarque la très
bonne qualité la formation du véhicule
capacité d analyse critique et dégager
les enjeux
c'est très agréable à entendre puisqu'en
fait vous poser les vraies questions
c'est à dire est ce qu on a un sentiment
d'appartenance à son université ou pas
il est faible en france c'est pour ça le
clown et senna est peu important
historiquement quelle est la place de
ceux de ses dons par rapport aux
engagements et au soutien de l'état
est ce que il s'agit de prendre le
relais ce que ces vies de diminuer la
part de l'état ou pas et enfin bien que
souhaitons mettre en avant et est
développé pour que les questions sont là
aussi justement vous parlez
d'implication des étudiants et que le la
bibliothèque universitaire est une
occasion pour cibler les étudiants sur
cette campagne je pense que il ya eu
même explicitement vous faites appel à
tous les étudiants sur le site internet
pour qu'ils deviennent ambassadeurs
participent à la collecte de fonds et
c'est ce qui est une idée pourtant
néanmoins d'en penser d'administration
on observe qu'il n'y a pas un seul
étudiant qui associé au conseil
d'administration
il n'ya pas d'étudiants il ya vingt
mille étudiants qui sont disponibles il
ya vingt mille étudiants qui peut être
pourrais apporter leur pierre à la
fondation
mais on leur demande de participer alors
qu'ils n'ont aucun pouvoir d' influence
sur sur la fondation politique d'avoir
tant que directeur qui définissait les
membres du conseil mettra science et non
mais je peux répondre en fait c'est le
c'est un sujet nouveau pour les
universités donc on apprend au fur et à
mesure l'université de la formation a
été créée en novembre 2011 elle a peu là
une activité tout à fait réduite et
lorsque la fondation d'écrire en
novembre 2011 et bien finalement on est
allé un peu au plus simple sur la
création du conseil d'administration et
donc effectivement c'est une fondation
partenariale c'est important que la
personne et morale même important de
l'université de la majorité des sièges
au conseil d'administration sont
occupées par deux représentants de
l'université à l'avenir
on nous souhaiterions faire évoluer la
composition du conseil d'administration
il y à des dispositions légales qui sont
dans les statuts de la fondation ça se
fait pas comme comme cela donc vous avez
tout à fait tout à fait raison
aujourd'hui la composition de ce conseil
ministration est pas et pas tout à fait
fascinante et je pense que c'est une
vraie question si paravent à la
formation c'est la fondation c'est aussi
être obligés de se tourner vers des
interlocuteurs et commencer à discuter
comment on le fait quitte à avoir des
critiques des suggestions en fait c'est
l'occasion comme de débattre c'est
l'occasion de débattre et la relation de
dons aussi même à partir de 15 euros
elle elle demande une contrepartie et le
début de ce dialogue justement vous
demandez quoi vous en contrepartie
donner 15 euros mais non mais moi je
déjà jeu
je demande en contrepartie simplement
que les étudiants et la communauté
universitaire puisse définir en
concertation avec avec la fondation
les projets pour cette fondation je veux
dire même en termes d'efficacité
applicative et d'orientation de la
fondation si vous voulez qu'il ya des
personnes qui participent
il faut leur faire au moins l'honneur de
les associer aux décisions
je veux dire c'est pas satisfaisant au
regard de regarder par exemple au
conseil d'administration de la faculté
il ya un taux d'abstention énorme tous
les ans comme dans toutes les facultés
vous me direz peut-être que même m des
étudiants conseil d'administration de la
fondation c'est pas assez
peut-être qu'il faut me passer à des
modes démocratique plus direct plus
implique hâtif qui permettent justement
aux étudiants de s'impliquer aussi
politiquement parce que la question
c'est ça on veut bien aider à donner des
dents et si c'est une ligne
si on nous prépare une université
sélective élitiste se ressemble à quoi
c'est un débat clair qu'est ce qu'on a
donné vous envie du coup de financer de
faire cet appel de 12 mois ce qui m'a
donné envie c'est simplement l'idée de
participer directement
à comment dire à la vie de l'université
alors je les fais sous forme monétaire
j'aurais pu faire autrement
national et la vida cette association
simple oui je suis partie de
l'association après voilà c'est cepici
pas pour ça que je suis là aujourd'hui
mais l'idée c'est vraiment de dire ok on
va faire quelque chose ensemble toute la
communauté universitaire et on va mettre
en place des outils démocratiques
innovants de façon à impliquer une large
partie de la population est juste je
voudrais à faire signaler que sur le
site internet quand on arrive sur la
première page des objectifs affichés
c'est attirer les meilleurs étudiants et
les meilleurs chercheurs
on est dans une dans une enquête de la
fondation six à là pour l'instant c'est
surtout là quand on arrive sur la page
d'accueil on voit plutôt la paix la
collecte oui bah vous allez
effectivement en dessous de la paix la
collecte vous verrez qu'il ya des
principes qui sont défendues par cette
fondation et moi j'aurais aimé que la
fondation porte un discours vis-à-vis de
l'état providence également parce que si
on porte la fondation ne porte pas ce
discours en même temps qu'elle appelle
aux dons la communauté universitaire et
la fondation a peut-être pas une
vocation à avoir un discours politique
non plus bas à un discours de
financement comme en mai le tas
providence est le plus grand donateur de
l'université peut-être qu'il faudrait
essayer de le convaincre plutôt lui pour
qu'on est con conserve aussi un cadre
démocratique
parce que bon c'est bien de mettre des
contreparties par exemple d'aller dîner
avec le président de l'université
quand on fait un don de 100 mille euros
mais moi je trouve que ça a déjà un peu
opaque de faire un achat relationnel
c'est peut-être un clin d'oeil et puis
ça vous a été donné sur les lieux on
vous avez été déjeuner avec jean luc
bussière
qu'est ce que je peux vous dire de ce
repas je peux rien vous dire ces deux
personnes qui ont discuté c'était un
petit clin d'oeil
oui c'est pas quelque chose d'été qui va
déterminer un don de 100 mille euros
enfin
mais non c'était c'est une manière de
montrer que en fait la question que vous
posez elle demande distinction entre
deux shows c'est que vous avez d'un côté
l'université l'université qui dont le
gel en connais qui sont ses missions de
service public d'accueillir tous les
étudiants sans sélection à l'entrée avec
un financement principal qui vient de
l'état et de l'autre côté vous avez la
fondation qui est la personnalité morale
qui est indépendante de l'université et
qui n'a pas vocation à se substituer à
elle ce que fait la fondation séquelles
c'est un outil au service astra j
l'université devrait la permettre
finalement de développer d'apporter 10
ans de développer des éléments sur
lesquels nous ne sommes pas son fort et
assez fort que nous jugions prioritaires
et sur la question des étudiants c'est
très clair l'université par ses missions
accueil tous les étudiants sans
sélection la fondation voudrait se
donner les moyens que parmi ces
étudiants qui vient à l'université lié
encore plus d'étudiants meilleur et que
notamment les étudiants qui pour des
raisons sociales ne peuvent pas
poursuivre leurs études dans les
conditions qui le souhaiteraient et bien
bénéficient de bourses
il y a des talents à l'université et
c'est le rôle de la fondation les
soutenir donc sur la question
démocratique que vous pose est qui et
qui est très importante en tant qu
encore une fois c'est on démarre quand
ces administrations vous avez des
ambassadeurs qui vont être l'implication
des étudiants et après on peut tout à
fait envisager sur les projets qui
seront menés qu'il y ait sur certains
projets une implication plus grande des
étudiants la présence sur les projets
qui sont directement de la recherche
pure c'est évidemment plus tôt les
chercheurs qui seront plus plus
important mais sur le projet commun en
carton qui est jeune talent du vécu qui
sont des soutiens des projets étudiants
aujourd'hui un étudiant brillant qui
veut monter quelque chose il n'y a pas
de fonds substantiels qui permettent
comme dans d'autres endroits comme dans
les
cole d'une anémone développer son projet
et là on pourrait très bien envisager en
avoir un conseil étudiant fins et après
il faut défendre la représentativité il
faut bien sûr on va travailler sur cela
mais bien entendu oui l'indication ce
qu' il en fait la fondation n'est
clairement pas un outil démocratique
puisqu'elle n'est pas accessible aux
étudiants
c'est pourtant moi je pense que là
l'outil démocratique dans un nous
associer à la fois d'efficacité et de
justice sociale
ça c'est un excellent excellente manière
de développer un projet je trouve
vraiment dommage qu'il n'y ai pas plus
d'initiatives qui soient prises
et puis alors l'idée d'un conseil c'est
ça reste vraiment à mon avis très bas
dans le sens des exigences qu'on
pourrait avoir par rapport à ce qu'on
peut apporter et je pense qu'il faudrait
vraiment impliquer les étudiants la
communauté universitaire directement
dans la décision des projets que va
apporter la fondation à mon avis c'est
le seul moyen de garder aussi une
démocratie universitaire l'a permis des
donateurs là par exemple cet exemple de
collecte de fonds par bibliothèque
universitaire ce que vous savez s'il ya
plus de d'étudiants que d'entreprises ou
de particuliers
vous savez à peu près le profil des
donateurs sur les vingt-six mille euros
hi
alors pour l'instant
je pense que vous êtes le seul étudiant
mais je me trompe peut-être il y a des
peut-être certains il ya des
particuliers qui sont pour certains des
parents d'étudiants ou alors d'anciens
personnel aussi qu'ils ont qui ont donné
après vous avez des entreprises
effectivement pour
pour l'instant et des membres actuels de
la communauté universitaire moi aussi
j'ai donné un moule pour pour accélérer
un peu plus longues et des étudiants de
participer à cette formation est de les
inclure la fonction d'ambassadeur est
ouverte à tout le monde vous êtes à dire
ça mais la fondation n'est pas une
institution représentative au sens il
n'ya pas elle n'est pas élue par les
différents corps il n'ya pas d'organe
électif comme dans une comme dans
l'université en fait c'est pas le les
stats une fondation
en revanche la porte est ouverte à tous
ceux qui veulent retrousser leurs
manches et je vais proposer des idées je
dirais que
clown nous démarrons la porte est
ouverte à tout le monde en fait proposer
des idées c'est bien moi je serai
heureux de le faire
sauf que si je n'ai pas de contrôle
politique sur lèze sur la fondation
pourquoi je le ferai au service de quoi
ce rallye je veux dire on vous pouvez
pas nous demander d'utiliser notre temps
et notre argent en tant qu'étudiant déjà
on n'en a pas beaucoup on a des emplois
pour financer la chollima ce cas comme
des choix où ça va faire des choix à
faire et si on n'a pas de contrôle
politique dessus pourquoi on ferait quoi
même si un souci d'efficacité par
rapport à votre fondation
si vous voulez que la fondation soit
efficace vous tourner aussi vers la
communauté universitaire il faut pas
prendre vivant
jacky par l'avion au canada étudiants il
faut ouvrir un petit peu plus à la
fondation
je voudrais revenir aussi sur un point
de vue la fondation des excuses c'est
pas la seule il ya d'autres fondations
jours a notamment cité aux sciences po
toulouse qui est acquis a été amené à
déménager en janvier dernier qu a lancé
un appel aux dons pour financer son
déménagement il ya l'université de
lettres et de langues de grenoble aussi
qui fait le choix aussi de se tourner
vers des mécénats pour financer son
université
ça veut dire quoi ça va quand même il ya
un désengagement de l'état il faut s'en
inquiéter
c'est parce que si les universités lance
un appel aux dons séquelles du coup
elles n'ont pas assez d'argent
c'est par des engagements de l'état
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on demande aux
universités dans un contexte qui est qui
et plus en plus concurrentiel
nationalement et internationalement
on leur demande de faire plus de faire
plus de se développer et donc autant les
financements de l'état sur les missions
de base et ça c'est du solide c'est de
l'incontestable autant si on souhaite
aller plus loin et bien et finalement il
faut se tourner vers les îles des
budgets et des budget complémentaire
je reviens sur la collecte de fonds pour
les ouvrages des bibliothèques
nniversaire c'est pour aller plus loin
parce que sur le site internet où il ya
beaucoup d'humour ans dans votre
d'autres appels à dons et vous dit on si
vous voulez avoir un bon avocat et moi
que cet avocat elle un code on se doute
que c'est comme pour acheter des
ouvrages qui sont pas des ouvrages de
base que vous avez vous demandé cette
collecte de fonds pour bibliothèques se
sont
deux ouvrages ou pas je ne sais pas
c'est le actualiser le sait la
réactualisation des collections c'est
indispensable pour avoir une production
de recherche de qualité c'est aussi
indispensable donc c'est pas du plus
c'est pas du plus c'est indispensable et
c'est la loi sur l'autonomie des
universités qui a permis de la création
de cette fondation des formations tout à
fait cesser de plus parce que si nous
prenons encore une fois le budget global
de la biotech universitaire envoyé
l'effort qui est fait par l'université
et dans le contexte où l'on connaît pour
lui vécu toutes les composantes de l'ue
est ce qu on fait des efforts tout pour
les laboratoires il faut imaginer pour
les laboratoires ses laboratoires
l'année dernière 25 % de leurs crédits
de fonctionnement ont été ouverts 25%
donc la biotech a été préservé par
rapport à ça
il faut il faut raisonner avec une avec
un budget global est donc le plus c'est
cette attaque le plus je crois c'est
vraiment de faire confiance dans le
savoir ce qui l'attend mentale personne
n'a jamais fait de campagne de levée de
fonds sans oublier personne
il me semblait que c'était on se
reconnaît plus dans ces valeurs plutôt
que de chercher le font pour faire venir
un professeur des états unis en offrant
un pont d'or plutôt que d'offrir voyez
des choses pour telle faculté il fallait
que ça se dirige vers l'ensemble de la
communauté universitaire et parlant je
reviens sur la question démocratique que
vous posiez 1 qu'il quitte en avant dans
ces cas là la formation n'est pas au
pack vous avez un commissaire aux
comptes vous avez un bilan d'activité et
vous avez un plan stratégique ce plan
stratégie comporte quatre axes et bien
avant de s'engager ou non pour la
fondation
libre à chacun de savoir s'il en accord
ou pas avec ces quatre axes prioritaires
et ses quatre axes peuvent être discuté
par le conseil d'administration
chaque année donc donc il y à une
procédure de la qui est totalement sans
une fondation en pack ne collecte pas de
fous ou alors cette fois-ci particulière
la transparence c'est une des conditions
de la démocratie
alors peut-être effectivement que je
pars opérait d'opacité particulière
néanmoins c'est pas un outil
démocratique je pense qu'en termes
d'efficacité j'en reviens dessus
c'est un problème si vous voulez
investir une communauté dans la collecte
de dons il faut lui donner du pouvoir
d'agir et d'une contrôle sur ce qui va
être fait autrement
elles sont d intéressant alors justement
installé dans les rues de saint quentin
pour demander aux habitants ce qu'ils
pensaient d'une université qui lance une
collecte de fonds mais coûte la réponse
dans une petite mesure ce serait plutôt
bénéfique mais ensuite faudrait pas que
ce soit complètement privatiser faire
appel aux entreprises c'est peut-être
mieux que faire appel aux étudiants même
si son seul moyen
si elle est bien obligée il faut
qu'elles le fassent peut-être bas je
pense que ça peut être pas mal ça peut
être pas mal parce que en plus soyez des
filières à l'université qui sont en
alternance
d'un côté c'est un peu aller théâtre
gérer ça le système universitaire et le
système éducatif le moins aidées par
l'état et c'est pas aux étudiants de
donner de l'argent pour leur fac alors
les avis sont assez partagés 1 c'est pas
c'est pas à l'université de demander aux
étudiants de financer ça c'est plutôt à
l'état c'est sympa un peu votre pour moi
c'est pas une bonne opposition
fondamentale je veux dire à condition
comme je disais tout à l'heure que la
fondation s'inscrivent dans un discours
d'incitation évidence à intervenir et
financé des universités voilà alors la
fondation a donc bien lancé un premier
appel aux dons pour la biotech
universitaire est ce qu'il ya d'autres
campagnes qui sont déjà prévues ou alors
fait campagne par campagne là cette
campagne de levée de fonds c'est une
campagne de mobilisation autour de
l'université le message c'est le suivant
c'est le département des yvelines a une
université est ce que c'est une chance
pour ce département ou pas ce territoire
est ce que l'on considère ou non que
pour être un territoire d'innovation
il faut s'appuyer sur l'ensemble des
acteurs et que ce secteur soit moins que
la zone est qu'ils ne le sont
aujourd'hui
sur le papier la situation rend
exceptionnel le tissu économique des
élus locaux de premier plan de plan
national une université on a un
potentiel qui est sous-exploité est donc
dans cette campagne de mobilisation
elle va nous servir après ça s'est
jamais fait de faire une campagne éclair
un sur la fois après de lancer une
campagne de levée de fonds pluriannuel
tête que ça se fait d'habitude
et justement sur cette campagne de levée
de fonds pluri annuel contre elle n'en
sera rien n'est pour l'instant fixée sur
les objectifs prioritaires à cette
campagne devait conclure annuel donc
cette campagne bibliothèque c'est le
lieu de pour commencer à créer une
communauté et discuter discuter une
débattre en fin de mois venez venez
rejoignez les ambassadeurs vous verrez
que les discussions sont très ouvertes
est-ce qu est-ce qu on peut rappeler un
peu les avantages fiscaux aussi pour
inciter peut-être les gens s'ils veulent
donner
oui pour les entreprises c'est les dons
sont défiscalisées
de 60 % avec une unique par rapport au
chiffre d'affaires et pour les
particuliers c'est 66%
la france un des régimes
de mécénat sur le plan fiscal un des
plus avantageux d'ailleurs la discussion
revient régulièrement pour essayer de
renier ce système tellement il est
tellement il est avantageux est-ce que
les donateurs ont un regard sur 100
l'argent ensuite par exemple ceux qui
vont donner pour les livres à l'égard
des caisses qu'ils ont un regard sur ce
sont le type de livres qui vont être
achetés ou pas du tout parce que vous
parliez tout à l'heure de contrepartie à
rester à une contrepartie quand on
essaie l'important est la contrepartie à
le mot était peut-être mal choisie est
la contrepartie c'est c'est une
interpellation
c'est un échange enfin quand quelqu'un
est bien quand quelqu'un décide de
soutenir la fondation
oui on lui doit un retour mais ça veut
dire quoi son argent a servi
c'est la première des choses sans argent
sale où il a un droit de regard sur
alors peut servir son argent
juridiquement la chose est très clair le
mécénat c'est une relation sans
contrepartie à la différence par exemple
d'un contrat de recherche universités
ont beaucoup de contrats de recherche
d'un contrat de recherche il peut y
avoir des clauses de propriété
intellectuelle dans le mécénat il n'y a
aucun droit de propriété acquis par la
relation de mécénat en revanche en
revanche pour comme c'est une c'est une
relation
comment dire c'est
c'est une inter relations il est normal
de donner aux mécènes la possibilité
bien de soutenir la partie qui me tient
le plus à coeur
s'ils le souhaitent donc par exemple
pour la bibliothèque il est possible de
flécher des les fonds en droit en
médecine ou en sciences humaines et
sociales par contre un mécène indienne
ne dira jamais je veux que tel il soit
ça a effectué un nom voyez c'est un fait
jeunes c'est l'un de ces enfants sont
des valeurs en fait c'est en fonction si
quelqu'un a des six a envie de soutenir
pour telle ou telle raison la médecine
eh bien il peut fléché sont denses
médecine il n'y a pas de droits voisins
pas des images sur la médecine
merci à vous d'être venu en remplaçant
donc pour évoquer notamment cette
fondation de l'ue vs qu qu'il vient donc
de lancer un appel de fonds pour des
livres à la bibliothèque un appel à
hauteur de 300 mille euros et c'est une
campagne qui a lancé jusqu'en juin 2015
donc on a du temps et pour l'instant 26
mille euros de collecter merci beaucoup
d'être venu soit pas trop de cette
petite société cette émission a
maintenant terminé merci de l'attention
et après bientôt